[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je reçois le journal de demain
aujourd'hui
je sauve la vie d'un maximum de gens
c'est bon boulot vous comprenez
[Musique]
super je sais pas s'il y en a dans la
salle qui connaît cette merveilleuse
série pour ceux qui connaissent pas je
vais vous expliquer un petit peu donc
cette série demain à la une c'est
l'histoire d'un gars ce merveilleux gary
hobson qui reçoit tous les matins devant
sa porte
un journal sur ce journal ya eu une à la
une du jour mais la lune du lendemain
généralement les nouvelles ne sont pas
très très bonne et et lui ce qu'il
cherche à faire c'est de transformer ces
nouvelles catastrophiques en bonne
nouvelle il ya quelques mois avec mon
équipe on a reçu ce journal et dont le
journal la ville de bagnols sur cèze
alors certains la connaissent une ville
à une heure de nîmes à peu près 18 mille
habitants et c'est la deuxième ville la
plus pauvre du département
alors comme gary hobson je me suis dit
il faut que j'essaye de changer cette
cette une
donc vous avez cette une avec en gros
titre les femmes du quartier des
escanaux privés de leurs droits par
manque d'accès au numérique en dessous
des détails
quelques chiffres pas très jojo 30 % de
familles monoparentales et un taux de
chômage des jeunes proches de 40 % juste
en dessous une image cette image c'est
la photo du quartier au premier plan
vous avez un square un square avec des
jeux pour enfants les jeux colorés qui
donne envie mais pas d'enfants pas de
femme non plus autour du jeu vous avez
des bancs avec des hommes qui discutent
entre eux je regarde cette une je me dis
mais ils sont où ces femmes et c'est
seulement à l'arrière-plan au fond de la
photo que j'aperçois des silhouettes
dans un bâtiment mais
arrive pas trop 3 à voir ce qui s'y
passe donc je me dis ça y est c'est
parti
enfile ton costume de gary hobson
évasive donc je ne suis pas gary hobson
je suis designer sociale alors quand on
dit designer social il ya design ya
sociale je suis d'accord ça va pas
vraiment bien ensemble en premier abord
design design c'est plutôt françois
disais tout à l'heure une chaise on va
penser à des couleurs à des belles
formes ça va être un produit qui est
innovant qui va être haut de gamme
social c'est plutôt des personnes des
interactions des inégalités des
personnes qui sont dans le besoin
le design social c'est une discipline
qui est centré sur l'humain
quand on fait du design par exemple on
va concevoir cette fameuse chaise on va
penser plutôt à sa fonction à son
assemblage mais ce qui va nous
intéresser
c'est la personne qui va venir s'asseoir
sur cette chaise on va leur prendre un
adulte d'une taille moyenne
on va prendre un adulte qui a des jambes
d'une taille moyenne aussi ça peut
servir et un point moyen on va réfléchir
au style de la chaise on va se dire soit
cette chaise à être sur un style plutôt
blanc et soft épuré tout ça tout ça ou
alors plutôt roots tapis berbères poils
de yack bref on est sur une conception
qui cherchent à satisfaire par dont le
plus grand nombre
on essaie de satisfaire l'industrie et
on est sur la standardisation
alors moi en tant que designer sociale
je veux pas satisfaire le plus grand
nombre
je veux pas satisfaire l'industrie et je
vais pas m'intéresser autant d'eau
tendance ce qui va m'intéresser dans le
design sociale c'est de travailler avec
les acteurs publics
je vais travailler avec eux pour essayer
de soutenir les politiques sociales
alors là de ce côté il ya tout qui va
bouger les modes de gouvernance on va
s'intéresser aux dispositifs de santé
aux aménagements publics à la gestion
crise tout ça en ce moment ça part dans
tous les sens et tout le monde s'y
intéresse
la mission du design sociale c'est de
faire pour et avec les personnes
concernées
avec ces méthodes on va pouvoir co créer
des espaces des objets et aussi des
services en tant que designer sociale
mon objectif est double premièrement je
vais essayer de comprendre
l'environnement d'une personne intimes
ou sociales d'ailleurs je vais voir ce
qui va pas fonctionner et je vais aussi
m'intéresser à ce qui déjà semble être
de bonnes idées deuxièmement une fois
avoir compris tout ça j'ai passé à l'aco
à la conception pardon et je vais
essayer de créer des choses qui vont
être adaptés aux besoins et aux envies
des personnes on va revenir à 7 une ce
journal
donc comment il nous arriver c'est le
gars qui nous l'a envoyé le sgar le
secrétariat général aux affaires
régionales
en gros c'est un système un système
pardon un service de l'état qui a pour
mission d'appliquer les politiques dans
le territoire régional
nous notre mission quand on a reçu ce
journal as c'était de réaliser une
expérimentation dans le quartier des
escanaux quartiers prioritaires de la
ville de bagnols et de donner des outils
de trouver des solutions pour sortir ces
femmes de ce2 ce2 comment dire de ce
ghetto enfin en tout cas de ce piège
dans lesquels n'avaient pas accès au
droit et tout ça grâce au numérique
bon
ce projet en plus dans cette cette
mission que nous donne le gars il a pour
objectif d'être un projet pilote
c'est à dire qu'il va falloir qu'on
puisse s'inspirer de ce projet pour le
dupliquer et l'adapter dans un autre
quartier
pourquoi on demande de travailler sur le
quartier des escanaux à bagnols sur cèze
pour en faire un projet pilote pour le
mettre sur un autre quartier en fait la
thématique
elle est très large on parle de la
dématérialisation des démarches public
et ça vous le savez ça concerne à peu
près tout le pôle emploi la caf le rsa
et même cette année les impôts alors aux
escanaux on commence quand même à s'y
préparer à cette histoire de
dématérialisation
pas sympa ce mot ils ont déjà mis en
place
donc les associations les gens qui
travaillent dans ce quartier là quelques
quelques ateliers
ces ateliers c'est l'accompagnement
numérique à l'informatique au multimédia
et dans ses ateliers déjà les femmes
représentent 65% des participants
notre mission donc c'est de changer
cette une
impossible donc pour ça on va commencer
à s'équiper
donc en tant que designer évidemment on
a nos crayons mais on a pas que ça on va
aussi essayer de concevoir nos propres
outils
on va on va aussi s'équiper enfin se
faire accompagner par un expert de
l'inclusion numérique
parce que moi en tant que designer
social l'inclusion numérique ça peut me
parler de loin mais je vais aller
rencontrer des femmes et des personnes
qui travaillent donc j'ai besoin d'avoir
des réponses qui soit pertinente et qui
reflète ce qui se passe en ce moment
comment on va s'y prendre pour réaliser
cette mission
on n'est pas gary hobson du coup on va
faire ça en
quatre étapes première étape l'immersion
l'immersion c'est quoi c'est simplement
qu'on va aller dans ce quartier là des
escanaux
on va y passer du temps et on va
rencontrer les personnes qui vivent on
va rencontrer les femmes et on va
rentrer aussi les personnes qui
travaillent les centres sociaux les
différentes associations
on va aussi passer dans une deuxième
étape qui est la co conception la loco
la co conception c'est simplement passer
de l'observation à la création d'idées
et la création d'idées dans
co-conception c'est à dire qu'on va pas
la faire tout seul on va la faire et
d'autres personnes ensuite on va passer
au prototypage c'est à dire qu une fois
qu'on aura créé et fait émerger plein
d'idées on va en sélectionné quelques
unes
et on va passer à une étape plus
tangible qui est le prototypage on va
faire des objets des maquettes et la
quatrième étape c'est la mise en test
c'est bien beau de créer des objets mais
faut voir si c'est si c'est faisable si
ça tient la route
une chaise il faut bien qu'on puisse
asseoir dessus pour voir si ces
résistants donc cette première phase
d'immersion
quand j'arrive en immersion ma dans ce
quartier que je connais pas je commence
par être fameux faire tout petit
j'observe et c'est en ayant quelques
quelques indices à droite à gauche son
voyant comment ça se passe que je peux
petit à petit
retirer mon camouflage et commencé à
poser des questions en fait je pose
beaucoup de questions après je veux ce
qui m'intéresse c'est le quotidien des
personnes et aller dans le détail de
leur vie
je vais donc rencontré des femmes et
alors quand on est sur la question de
l'inclusion numérique et qu'on arrive à
un quartier des escanaux à bagnols on a
des réponses comme le numérique un an
moi j'ai pas ça sur mon téléphone
bon alors c'est cette réponse
elle m'a quand même apporté de réponse
la première c'est la question de la
langue
en effet comment on peut se dire je vais
aller sur internet je veux prendre mon
ordinateur je vais déclarer mes impôts
en ligne tout ça tout ça j'aurai accès à
mes droits si on
même pas lire le français ou l'écrire ou
le parler encore la deuxième réponse
c'est celle du vocabulaire en tant que
designer sociale quand on est sur le
terrain et qu'on discute avec les
personnes concernées
on est un peu le traducteur entre ce que
les politiques veulent faire appliquer
sur le territoire est ce que les
personnes qui vivent sur le territoire
peuvent entendre
donc on a rencontré des femmes et on a
aussi rencontré des professionnels et là
du côté du professeur des professionnels
c'était assez cocasse on a rencontré
donc notamment de professionnels qui
faisait la même chose même objectif même
public mais qui se connaissaient pas du
tout
ou alors de loin mais qui avait jamais
pris le temps d'échanger entre eux bon
après c'est normal au bon on les excuses
elle était distantes l'une de l'eau de
haut - l'épaisseur d'un mur bon ça c'est
facile de le voir parce que moi j'arrive
là j'ai un oeil j'ai un oeil extérieur
un oeil neuf
donc évidemment jeu mais le jeu mais les
les pieds dans la mare une fois cette
première étape de l'immersion fait on
passe à cette deuxième étape qui est la
co conception
alors là l'objectif c'est donc de
rassembler les différentes personnes qu
on a croisé pendant cette phase
d'immersion et de commencer à faire
émerger des idées qui vont solutionner
tous les problèmes qu'on avait rencontré
qu'on avait relevé est ce qu'on veut à
ce moment là c'est que les solutions qui
vont être créés à destination des femmes
et des personnes qui n'a rien d'un
quartier soit fait avec celles qui vont
les utiliser alors là ce que vous voyez
derrière moi c'est un plan pendant la
phase d'immersion
on a essayé de lister les différentes
aides qui était proposé aux femmes pour
avoir un accès au numérique et un accès
à leurs droits
donc là on a essayé de représenter tout
ça on a mis des petits des petits
drapeaux et l'objectif de cet outil que
vous voyez là c'est que les femmes
puisse nous dire moi ça je connais ça je
connais pas et rajouter aussi des
informations que moi je n'avais pas
perçu et si on s'intéresse à cette
représentation
là ce plan c'est parce que souvenez vous
cette photo qui était sur la une du
journal y avait pas de femme et moi ce
qui m'intéresse à ce moment là c'est de
me dire bon si je crée des solutions
pour les femmes va falloir un moment
qu'elles qu'elles en aient connaissance
et pour ça ces femmes elles vont pas
recevoir l'information dans leur boîte
mail on est d'accord
donc il faut que ce soit dans l'espace
public et c'est à ce moment là que les
femmes vont pouvoir me dire d'alors moi
je veux jouer je vais faire mes courses
ici je passe par ici je m'installe
devant l'école en attendant mon enfant
c'est d'ailleurs là aussi qu'on a appris
que les femmes du quartier ne se
retrouvait pas dans le quartier
c'est dans un quartier ça parle beaucoup
non qu'elle a eu juste décalé à quelques
buissons près ailleurs mais au moins là
on sait qu'il ya un endroit stratégique
dans lequel on va pouvoir discuter avec
ces femmes
on passe ensuite à la troisième phase
qui est la phase de prototypage à la
phase de prototypage c'est simplement
simplement passer du dessin au 2d à
quelque chose de plus de plus volumineux
à des maquettes à des objets on va on va
créer différents différents objets on va
créer des bd des jeux on va on va créer
des guides et notamment on va
transformer se planque était une vue
google maps vue du dessus dans lesquels
les femmes finalement pendant l'atelier
ancenis rendu compte ne se repérer pas
on va transformer ce plan en une
représentation d'une illustration dans
lesquels on va pouvoir dessiner des
lieux que les femmes connaissent et
peuvent reconnaître cette phase de
prototypage elle et elle est pour moi
très importante parce que c'est à ce
moment là où ça va être beaucoup plus
facile pour celles qui vont utiliser les
objets de pouvoir
discuter avec nous surtout pour ces
femmes qui pour la plupart ne parlent
pas vraiment bien français avec un objet
entre les mains c'est plus facile de
dire là ça marche pas ça je comprends
pas cette couleur elle n'est pas bonne
j'arrive pas à lire et c'est ensuite
venir le test donc le test là c'est
aussi plus un peu plus abouti c'est à
dire que bon les fans nous ont fait un
premier retour sur ça j'arrive pas
j'arrive pas à le comprendre mais là
c'est plutôt du côté aussi des pros ou
rappelez vous on est dans un quartier
prioritaire où il ya beaucoup
d'associations qui travaillent et là bas
les petites races aux petites dents dans
la taille un pas dans ce qu'elles font
elles n'ont pas beaucoup de moyens ils
ont au mieux une imprimante avec de
temps en temps des problèmes mais en
tout cas une imprimante à 4 et elles ont
surtout d urgence d urgence parce que
dans quelques mois les impôts en ligne
ils seront là donc ce qu'on veut faire
pendant cette phase de test c'est voir
quels moyens on peut mettre dans les
mains des professionnels pour qu'il
puisse se saisir de nos outils
dès qu'on soit partie de cette mission
aujourd'hui on est donc parti de ce
quartier là deux parties des escanaux et
on a pu laisser dans les mains des
professionnels est dans les mains des
femmes
cet outil donc on a laissé cet outil
dans les mains des pots et des femmes on
les a laissés et actuellement ils sont
dans une phase d'expérimentation sur six
mois ça va être testé cet été testés et
retester pour pouvoir j'espère aboutir à
quelque chose de ces fini d'assez fin
qui répondent à des besoins précis la
une du journal qu'on est en train de
retravailler est en bonne voie grâce à
ce projet on a réussi à créer des à
créer des liens on a créé des connexions
à créer des connexions entre les
professionnels et entre les femmes
on a aussi créé des connexions entre les
femmes et les professionnels
quand on travaille sur une question
numérique on s'attend forcément à des
solutions technophiles
mais là ce qu'on a fait c'est plutôt des
solutions aux frugal peu coûteuse qui
comme je vous le disais vont répondre à
un besoin une île
il faut agir dans l'immédiateté c'est
pour ça que travaille avec des morceaux
de carton avec du papier avec des choses
qui sont imprimables dans des fonds dans
des petits formats permettent cette mise
en action il ya ce changement immédiat
aujourd'hui les projets à thématiques
sociales sont pour la plupart portés par
des collectivités
ces collectivités on le sait elles ont
du mal à innover
les départements les régions tout ça
c'est pas ils sont pas très connus pour
leur capacité d'innovation en tout cas
c'est un peu un peu lent faut dire
qu'ils sont ils ont sur leurs épaules un
cadre protocolaire qui est assez assez
lourd en tout cas le ce gars était pas
le seul acteur à nous avoir fait
parvenir ce cette une
il ya d'autres acteurs dans le dans le
coin qui qui nous envoient des tonnes et
des tonnes de journaux ya la région qui
est très intéressé par sa qui a
d'ailleurs essayé de s'équiper de ces
méthodes de design social traire la
création d'un laboratoire au sein même
de la région il ya le département qui
s'intéresse très fortement à ça même à
nîmes il ya carrément un centre de
recherche et un master qui créent des
designers sociale on a besoin de
guerriers hobson je crois et si gary
hobson galerie hobson ces anglais arrive
à changer la une du journal avec son
courage son intelligence ses gros
muscles pour ma part c'est en donnant la
parole en valorisant l'expertisé usages
de chacun que je peux tenter d'arriver à
changer cette une en ligne une plus
souhaitable et plus désirable merci
[Musique]